The road trip from Seattle
to Vancouver takes about three hours.
There's pretty scenery
to look at along the way
and a really exciting border to cross.
Once you make it into British Columbia,
everything changes in an instant.
It's like entering another world.
In Vancouver, most public servants
are required to drive Teslas,
so you see the things
just about everywhere.
All of the clocks here run
on steam and play songs.
And the airports are in the water.
Oddities like these aside,
it would be hard to dream
up a more beautiful city,
beautiful mountains, beautiful buildings,
beautiful geese, beautiful
graffiti complimented
by beautiful, filthy alleyways.
And if you know the right spots,
you can eat like a king in Vancouver.
This counts as a light lunch in Chinatown.
That is good.
And if you know the right guy
at the right hole in the wall,
you can get what you need.
It's pure.
But I'm in Vancouver for more
than just mainlining maple syrup.
There are people who would say
that building a super lifelike,
extremely intelligent
robot is a terrible idea,
the kind of thing that could lead
to the downfall of the human species.
But today, I will visit a
startup called Sanctuary A.I.
They've built this crazy robot
that has artificial
intelligence baked into it.
And it also has these
very life-like hands.
Sanctuary claims to have the smartest,
most capable android on the planet.
The only thing we can say for certain
is that because the robot
is being built in Canada,
it will be ridiculously polite.
I'm sorry.
Excuse me.
My bad.
Sanctuary A.I. was started
by a handful of engineers in 2019.
The company's CEO is this fella,
and its Chief Technology
Officer is Suzanne Gildert.
If Suzanne looks familiar to some of you,
that's because she's been
on "Hello World" before.
Her previous company was called Kindred,
and it made robotic arms
that could pick and
place items in factories.
Suzanne's new company is a
lot like her old company,
only better.
Do you wanna shake hands?
Yeah, absolutely.
Nice to meet you.
So this is a general-purpose robot.
It's humanoid in form and function.
It's designed to be good
at doing work tasks.
Do I call it an it?
How do we refer?
I usually refer to the robot as Eric.
Eric is our pilot who you'll see
taking control of the robot.
He will be our operator today.
Hi Eric.
Hey.
I think people have seen
robots at a car factory.
But like, walk us through
some of the advances
you guys have made, you know,
versus that type of machine.
Most robots you'll find in
industry are special purpose
and they're programmed
in a very different way.
They're programmed to do a repetitive task
over and over again, so that robot,
it doesn't really know where things are,
it's just executing some
pre-written routines.
So what we're trying to
do here is build a robot
that is actually aware
of its surroundings,
that's building up a mental model
of everything it's seeing in real time,
and is therefore able
to do different tasks,
more general-purpose tasks.
And then a big part of that
would be the dexterity of the hands.
I know that you guys have
been focusing on that
for quite some time.
Yeah, these are sort of about
the fourth-generation
hands that we've built.
So maybe Eric, you can hold out your hand,
I can show some of the features.
So obviously a human-like
hand, four fingers and a thumb.
These things you see here are sensors.
That gives the robot a
haptic sense of touch.
When these pressure sensors are pressed,
the data signals go
into the software system
and they're also relayed to the pilot.
So Eric has like,
a glove on.
Yes.
And he can feel?
Eric, you can feel
that, when you're poked?
Uh, yeah.
Why don't we play a game of chess.
Okay.
And we can talk
through some of the
components while we do that.
All right, so you're white.
You go first, right?
Yeah, sounds good.
Should have pre-planned my move.
I will be using the Sicilian defense,
just to let you know.
Oh, seems I might be outmatched.
Eric, when you're doing this, I mean,
are you just seeing the piece like I am,
or there's some sort of guide,
like do you have a helmet on?
Yes, I do.
I have a VR headset.
So what I'm seeing is stereo vision
through the camera you're looking at.
Yeah, you can almost
see behind you, right?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't even see
the camera over here.
I think that probably if people saw this
for the first time and then they hear
that there's a human operator behind it,
they would kind of be like, "Oh, well,
I wanted the full robot."
Yeah.
So a lot of people ask, well, you know,
isn't this just a person
behind the scenes?
But having a person behind the scenes
allows us to gather lots of
very human-like training data
to train the software system,
train the A.I. algorithms
to be more human-like over time.
So we're currently just using VR rigs.
Off the shelf gear, but we're planning
on having some new rigs made
that actually give force
feedback to the pilot as well.
So Eric, can you hold your arm out?
And if I did this, the
pilot would actually
be able to feel the
force feedback as well.
These robots are designed
to work alongside people,
so we need them to be very safe.
And one of the things about
this robot and its motor system
is it actually operates in
a force-controlled mode.
So what that means is the robot
will try and hold the position of the arm,
but if a maximum force is applied
that is greater than a
certain force, it will give.
Tell me a little bit
about your background,
just 'cause I know you've
been into electronics
and computing since you were a kid, right?
Well, I've loved electronics and robotics
and things like that since I was little.
I did a degree in physics
and a Ph.D. in physics
and electronics, too.
And then from there, I worked
in the quantum computing space
for a while and eventually
found my way into A.I.
You grew up in the UK?
Yeah, that's right.
And I know like outside of this,
you have all these interesting
tech related pursuits.
Yeah, so I have quite a lot
of interesting hobbies that I do.
I do like to do paintings.
They've kind of moved towards
a more tech electronics theme
and they're actually inspired
a lot by computer history.
So a lot of the paintings you'll see
are things like close ups
of old microprocessors.
There are even a few that are
like robot power circuits.
So always thinking about robots.
Whose move is it Eric?
I believe it's your turn.
I'm not gonna lose to an A.I. human.
Team human.
Okay, okay.
I'm okay with that strategy.
Chess is a really interesting
game for several reasons.
One is that it's fairly easy
now for software systems
to solve the intellectual part of chess.
It's been historically used in A.I. many,
many, many times for teaching machines.
What we're really trying
to show here, though,
is that it's the parts of
chess that people find easy,
like picking up a piece, moving it,
knowing where all the
pieces are on the board,
those are the parts that
people find very easy.
Computer algorithms find
that part extremely hard.
But also chess is a stand-in
for all different kinds of activities
that you might have to
do in the world of work.
Maybe things need organizing
in the right locations.
You need to take stock of
items in a retail store.
Or you could imagine
instead of chess pieces,
these were small parts on an
assembly or a sortation line.
I mean, the goal is eventually then,
the robot is just smart enough,
it's just doing its own thing
with maybe no human operator in some jobs.
Yeah, for certain tasks.
So I'd like to see this robot
system be able to automate
the really mundane,
boring parts out of the--
Sorry, I've got to readjust something.
I would appreciate if you
gave me a minute or two.
I'll just let him adjust that
and move out of the wave his arm.
So I'd like to see these robots
doing the sort of boring,
mundane parts of tasks, and
then the pilots are now freed up
to be more like the overseers
or the managers of the group of robots.
So you can imagine a group of
robots all being controlled
by a single pilot,
almost like the person
becomes more of a manager
and the robots become more
like the manual workers.
Okay.
So about 95% of all jobs,
the dexterity of the fingers
precludes conventional robotic
systems from doing them.
So we have attempted to build
the world's best robotic hands
because hands are really
important for work.
So we are working on integrating
state of the art robots,
specifically for manipulation
of the world through hands
with a new kind of A.I.
system that integrates
a lot of the tools that
people have been developing
around the world into a
platform that's intended
to give these robots the kind
of understanding of the world
that is kind of a baseline for work.
It's interesting because I think
there's definitely people who would look
at what you guys are making and
go, "Great, now you're going
to take all these factory
jobs from people."
Well, it's not, it's not taking jobs.
In fact, I think that it's
starting to be recognized
that the problem that we face
in terms of the employment labor market
is actually the opposite problem.
There aren't enough people
to do the kinds of work
that needs to get done to support
the continued flourishing of
civilization, our way of life.
There are more than 11
million unfilled positions
in the US right now.
The world needs more workers,
especially in the kinds of jobs
that people typically don't want to do,
those 11 million open jobs right now.
Those are the kinds of things
that we're going to target,
and that's a big number.
And 11 million jobs, it's
only going to grow over time.
Birth rates are plummeting
and 11 million robots
of our sort in the world doing those jobs
doesn't take a single
job away from anyone,
but 11 million robots out in the world
is an enormous business.
It's starting to become
at the scale of the automotive industry.
And I do believe that this is
the birth of a new industry.
It sort of looks like robotics
and it sort of looks like A.I.
But it's a new thing
and it's going to rival
the biggest industries there are today
in importance and scale
when it gets going.
Okay, so you're moving in on me quick.
Distracting me with your fancy hands.
I'm going to deal with your knight
because it's really bothering me.
Ah, my knight.
Yeah, he's a troublemaker.
Yeah.
What did you get up to this weekend?
You know, just robot
stuff, a lot of chess.
I was practicing for you.
I know you're pretty good.
Ooh, I don't like that.
I will take this and put it over here.
Not cool, not cool.
Oh yeah.
You don't miss a beat man.
All right, I will concede.
I can see you've got me beat.
Very good game, well played.
Thank you sir, thank you.
So we saw Eric as the pilot
picking up the chess pieces quite easily,
using his human mind.
And here the robot is trying
to learn what it means
to actually pick up a chess piece
in the same way that a human would.
And it does it by trying
over and over and over again.
So on this screen over here,
you can see a close up of it
trying to grab a chess
piece and you'll see
it sort of fumbles around
a little bit at the start.
But after enough training episodes,
it will learn to grab it
in a very human-like way.
There's not obviously 10,000 robot arms.
This is all simulated.
Yeah, so here, we can have thousands
or hundreds of thousands of hands
trying to pick things up
faster than real time.
So you're accelerating the learning rate
by millions of times.
So the physics engine, the
rules that have been put
into the software to mimic like gravity
and the different properties of our world
are good enough that this is
actually training the hand.
Yeah, they're getting there.
So if you think about where
you could have done this many,
like a few years ago,
you might think, well,
"I could use a game engine maybe"
because game engines are
pretty good simulated worlds.
But then when you get
deep into game engines,
you find they're sort of
optimized to make games look good.
They have a lot of animations in them.
They don't have a lot of real physics.
So we're actually bootstrapping
on game engine technology,
but there are now
systems going beyond that
and trying to mimic physics very well.
And so even something like the interaction
of the end of a fingertip with an object
has to be modeled very well.
So you need a really good physics engine.
What do we have here?
Yeah, so we saw the grasping
algorithm being trained.
What we're actually seeing here
are those grasps being realized.
It's taking what it's learned
and putting it into practice.
So it's motion planning,
not just the grasp anymore,
but that in combination
with the entire movement
of the robot body.
Your eyes kinda lit up when
you were talking about this.
Why?
Yeah, so when you just look
at this from the outside,
it's like, "Oh, a virtual
robot is moving a chess piece.
So what?"
But to me, this is like
a spark of life moment
because what you're actually seeing
is fully autonomous grasping
and manipulation of an object in a scene
where none of this is pre
programmed or specified.
It's figuring out where those pieces are
just by looking at the
scene, looking at them.
You can see in this view,
it's actually trying
different potential grasps.
And then it's actually executing the move
using real physics.
Okay, you've got this virtual robot
getting more sophisticated
and doing these things.
But like, in my head,
I feel like the second
you have the real robot,
there's going to be all these differences
and the chess piece
and the physics between
the hand and the pieces.
There are still some discrepancies
between reality and the simulation,
but that gap is closing
all the time and to me,
this could transfer and generalize
to other types of
objects, other scenarios.
So rather than just
thinking about a chess game,
think about cutlery being
laid out in a restaurant
or something like that.
So what we're seeing now is we are seeing
a little bit of a peek inside
the A.I. mind when it's running.
Okay.
So if you remember earlier,
we saw the VR type of piloting.
Imagine now, instead of
having to control the robot
with all this VR gear,
you just have a dropdown list of options.
So you can see there are two screens here.
This one we call the outer world model.
So this is a digital twin of reality.
This is a simulation of the world
and it's a simulated robot.
Now, this one down here is
the robot's mental model
of the world, so this is inside its mind.
Okay.
And this is outside its mind.
So you'll see the main difference
between these two at the
moment, it's pretty obvious.
There is a chessboard with the pieces here
and it's not here.
So the reason is that the robot
is not looking at the chessboard.
Okay.
And it's never seen it before,
so it doesn't have a mental
model of the chessboard.
But say I'm now a pilot here.
I can use the command "look down" here.
We're now controlling the
simulated robot look down.
And now you can see the
chessboard appeared here.
So now this, it's building
up this inner mental picture
of what's going on in real time.
Yeah, they're all like moving around.
Yeah, so they're jostling
around a little bit.
And the reason is, is that
these are all being detected
and figured out what
they are in real time.
Okay so this is super
interesting what happened.
Down here, a bunch of the
pieces have disappeared.
It's like blocking it's vision, or...
Yeah, so see the hand is
in front of the pieces?
I think it's like a six month old baby.
If you show it something
and then you hide it--
Like peekaboo.
It thinks it's gone.
So, that's a very human-like
trait of a developing mind
is to go through this stage
where if you can't see it,
it doesn't exist.
So what we really want to
get to here is this robot
in any real-world scenario
would roll into a room,
it would look around and
it would start building
a mental model of everything
it was seeing in real time,
including the room and all the objects
and what they are and
where they're located.
It's funny because in some ways,
I'm picturing my head like 1960s sci-fi,
like an android that is moving around.
And what you guys are making
is still sort of in some ways
people's first conception of
where all this was heading.
Well, I think so, yeah.
And I like to think of Sanctuary's mission
as going back to the sort
of original vision of A.I.
when people like Alan
Turing and Marvin Minsky
and these people were thinking about,
"How do we actually
make a machine or system
that thinks and behaves like a person?"
If we want systems to be able to work
in the same way people do,
interact with us in
the same way people do,
they need a human-like body
and a very human-like intelligence.
And you think the
dystopian stuff is all...
You're optimistic by nature or
you think it's all overblown?
If we manage to develop
fully autonomous A.I.
in a general-purpose robot, you might ask,
"What will that look like?
How will it change the world?
What's going to be going on?"
But you saw it earlier, right,
it'll look exactly like it
did when Eric was piloting.
It's just there won't be a
person in a VR suit in there.
So I would ask you, well,
was that scary and
terrifying and dystopian?
Right.
And I also think if you are focusing
on a very optimistic future
where you have robots
working alongside people, helping people,
I think you will make
that future come to pass.
You get people accusing you
of being naively optimistic.
But I think you need
that if you want to make
that future real and if you're
really optimistic about it,
it's more likely to happen.
I promise I'm smiling behind the camera.
Do robots say cheese?
Yeah, absolutely.
Alright, one, two, three.
Cheese.
Cheese!